rodas o engrenagens um eterno fortes
espasmos retidos em maquinismos em fúria
letras falantes gritos visuais ordem de
uso abuso reincidência costume hábito
premência indispensabilidade e com o
excesso contemporâneo de voz ou máquinas
eu sou a coisa com exatamente essas duas
palavras de carlos drumond de andrade e
álvaro de campos que define exatamente o
que é ser um jovem no século 21 um jovem
que deixou de ser gente e passou a ser
coisa uma coisa que deve ser competente
produtiva perfeita e uma coisa feliz mas
o problema é que essa coisa não tá feliz
ela está se matando no brasil nos
últimos 30 anos a taxa de suicídio dos
jovens aumentou em quase 30 por cento
só que o que aconteceu de 30 anos pra cá
o que mudou que está fazendo os jovens
começarem a se matar cada vez mais
bom a gente entrou em um período e esse
período se chama hipermodernidade a
hipermodernidade nada mais é do que uma
aceleração em uma intensificação da
modernidade no sentido de uma cultura da
perfeição e da eficiência
nesses tempos acelerados como que a
hipermodernidade se dá de maneira
prática na nossa vida é como se ela
fosse um povo que tem tentáculos em
várias esferas pessoais
o primeiro tentáculo desse povo é a
popularidade quando os amigos que a
gente tem a gente sente que a gente tem
que estar sempre mostrando que a gente
tem vários contatos e várias redes
o corpo qualquer nossa aparência perante
a sociedade ea companhia escolar a nossa
eficiência que tem que se mostrar a cada
vez ea nossa aparência e compras a gente
sente que está sempre na moda
só que ter todo esse contexto é moderno
afeta a saúde mental dos jovens é
importante pontuar que normalmente
quando a gente fala sobre saúde mental
muitas pessoas pensam em depressão
ansiedade ou algum outro transtorno mas
não significa necessariamente ter a
ausência dessas enfermidades
você pode ter vários outros critérios
para ter saúde mental que normalmente
são definidos pela oms
um deles é ter atitudes positivas em
relação a si próprio e não é incomum ver
pessoas que têm é atitudes negativas em
relação a eles mesmo mas não
necessariamente têm algum transtorno bem
quando a gente vê esses problemas que
estão tendo com os jovens atualmente em
relação à saúde mental
a gente pode relacionar eles diretamente
com a sua identidade
então a gente considere densidade um
fator muito cultural e tendo isso em
mente a gente entende que a
hipermodernidade ela traz a noção de
liberdade pra gente
só que a gente questiona será que essa
liberdade que a gente está tendo
realmente vem da nossa essência ea nosso
desejo
imagina só que você se olha no espelho
mas você não consegue ver sua face
desesperador né
é isso que o rené magritte estava
pensando quando ele pintou esse quadro
mas o que ele quer dizer com isso
esse quadro simboliza o que é ser um ser
humano da hipermodernidade você se olha
no espelho você tenta achar o que você é
o que faz de você você mas está tão
confuso e bombardeado pela nossa cultura
da perfeição e com as nossas ilusões de
liberdade que você não consegue saber
mais que você e todo esse contexto de
insalubridade e angústia e moderna nos
chegou a fazer um projeto de praia na
sessão científica
esse projeto foi feito com mil
adolescentes em escola pública e escola
particular em que a gente traz o
correlações entre as a identidade foi
moderna ea sua saúde mental
o primeiro critério que a gente vai
falar sobre co
o corpo é muito mais que uma estrutura
biológica
ele tem influências sociais esses
padrões esses ideais inatingíveis
tudo isso influencia a nossa vida então
por exemplo o adolescente começa a
espinha porque ele está entrando na
puberdade uma pessoa mais velha começa a
ter rugas a gente tenha necessidade de
esconder isso o máximo possível porque a
gente quer negligenciar os fatores
biológicos e conseguir se moldar cada
vez mais desse padrão que na venda
teve uma frustração eterna porque a
gente não consegue ea gente viu que a
escola pública
muitas vezes se esse padrão e como é
muitas vezes é elitista
esses jovens da escola pública têm muita
dificuldade de conseguir se moldar
podendo desenvolver por exemplo é falta
de percepção da sua realidade então que
significa significa mais ou menos que o
jovem ele consegue muitas vezes se olhar
no espelho só que ele não consegue se
ver
então ele se vê é por exemplo pode ter
teorias corporais como bulimia anorexia
e entre outros problemas de saúde mental
enquanto na escola particular teve uma
reverberação um pouco curiosa porque a
gente viu que um jovem se preocupava em
atingir o ideal do corpo perfeito
muitas vezes ele sentia mais integral
ele sentia melhor com ele mesmo ea gente
viu já parou pra pensar
e reparou que isso é porque esse jovem
escola particular muitas vezes ele tem a
condição monetária para tentar buscar
esse ideal então ele pode fazer a
cirurgia plástica no nariz fazer
chapinha comprar as melhores roupas da
moda
só que a gente entende que isso é uma
ilusão de estar bem porque ele ainda
está buscando um ideal que ele nunca vai
atingir o segundo critério seria a
aparência e cobras
mas o que é isso exatamente isso tem a
ver com a nossa necessidade incessante
de estar na moda mas está na moda não é
somente as roupas que você usa o sapato
que você calça
isso também tem a ver com o atualizado
você está nos meios nas piadas ou
consciente você tá das coisas que estão
acontecendo a todos os momentos a gente
viu que nas escolas públicas
você pensa identidade fortemente baseada
em aparente compras faz você desenvolver
falta de percepção apurada da realidade
isso tem a ver com o bombardeado
adolescente fica com anúncios e
propagandas
enquanto isso distorce a necessidade
versus o querer enquanto na escola
particular
esse jovem tinha uma dificuldade de
aceitar as exigências da vida é tipo
típica pessoa mimada que consegue ter o
consumo perfeito quase ideal mas muitas
quando está à frente é uma
responsabilidade não sabe lidar com ela
o terceiro critério é o critério da
popularidade
a gente sabe popularidade sempre foi
algo que incomodou os seres humanos
provavelmente vocês na época de escola
conhecia aquela pessoa que tinha um
grande mas muitos amigos e se sentia
mais integrado no ambiente
o problema é que na item modernidade
essa popularidade ela foi distorcida não
é mais sobre a quantidade de amigos que
você tem é sobre números
então você tem dois seguidores você tem
mil seguidores
você tem 10 likes você tem 201 jovem
escola pública que ele buscava esse
ideal de ter a melhor quantidade de
amigos possível
muitas vezes ele tinha uma falta de alta
determinação e ele tinha uma dificuldade
de reconhecer seus limites
então aquela pessoa que abra mão de sua
identidade dos em ciência para tentar se
adequar e por último a gente vai falar
de competência escolar com a aceleração
do tempo e a hipermodernidade intensa
nossas cabeças
a gente tenha necessidade de achar que a
gente tem que tá produtivo toda hora
então a pessoa que é viciada no trabalho
um aluno que só tira nota 10 não pode
errar nunca é a gente vê isso como um
objetivo só que na verdade essas pessoas
também estão fazendo mal para si mesmo a
gente viu que o jovem na escola pública
por exemplo
eles têm é eles têm muita dificuldade de
atingir o objetivo deles por conta de
falta de recursos então esse jovem que
quer que é um meio de tirar uma nota tão
boa que almeja entrar numa faculdade
muito é boa ele normalmente é não
consegue e ele entra nesse tipo de
frustração ele não consegue estar bem
consigo mesmo
só que no contraste a gente viu que o
jovem da escola particular ele consegue
só que com a olimpíada ganhando medalha
e isso não significa que ele
necessariamente está bem porque a gente
viu que quando ele busca desse ideal por
mais que ele receba esse feedback
positivo é sem dificuldade de reconhecer
seus limites
então aquela pessoa que sempre ganha
apenas retira 10 e participa de 1.000
extracurriculares
só que passa a noite
era sem dormir estudando para continuar
recebendo esse feedback
bom agora vocês podem perguntar pra
gente não tem esperança nenhuma a gente
vai viver desse jeito que a gente está
vivendo agora e não tem nenhuma
possibilidade da gente mudar como a
sociedade
bom a gente vai contar pra vocês um
pouco do que é razão comunicativa
o sociólogo que criou com tecido
hipermodernidade rabello mas ele também
criou esse conceito de razão
comunicativa que seria a possibilidade
da gente como sociedade se humanizar de
novo mas como que a gente vai fazer isso
primeiro você acha de coisas absurdas
então você pega aquele ideal que você
tem e você reticular isa ele é então não
é natural a gente achar que a gente
pular uma refeição porque a gente quer
entrar num padrão é normal não é normal
você sair fazendo a lição de casa dos
seus amigos pra ter alguém com quem você
quer andar na escola e não é normal você
se sente culpado quando você está de
férias porque você acha que você tem que
estar constantemente produzindo e também
a gente precisa fazer trocas de símbolos
humanos em detrimento dos símbolos do
mercado ou seja parar de falar de um
wiki de dinheiro de moda e começar a
falar sobre sentimentos perguntar para o
outro como ele está sentindo frente uma
situação e trocar experiências
essa troca de símbolos humanos
aliada a começar a achar as coisas mais
absurdas e desnaturalizar comportamentos
seria um passo pra gente começar a
construir uma identidade que é autêntico
mas o que seria essa identidade é
autêntica é a gente começar a perceber
que as coisas não têm uma importância
inerente a elas que as coisas elas têm a
importância que a gente dá pra elas
então pega por exemplo o enem o enem é
uma prova e claro é super importante
para a sua vida é importante para o
brasil
só que querendo ou não é a sua nota
daquela prova tem a importância que você
dá pra ela e se você não achar que
aquilo é importante pra você não precisa
ser
é assim que a gente vai começar a
construir uma identidade mais autêntica
e mais nossa abraçando as coisas
op fiz meus irmãos carrega o peso da dor
como se portasse medalhas uma coroa um
milhão de dólares ou coisa que o valha
arre estou farto de semideuses onde que
a gente no mundo
será que só eu que é phil errôneo nessa
terra opzz édens analgésicos
não-me-toque nessa dor ela é tudo que me
sobra e sofrer vai ser a minha última
obra
essas são as palavras de levynsky e
álvaro de campos e para elas e essas
palavras significam pra gente é muito
mais o que elas significam basicamente a
gente precisa começar a incorporar a
nossa dor incorporar nossos defeitos
construir nossa identidade de maneira
mais autêntica e abraçar nós as
importâncias de maneira a não
desvalorizar as coisas que a gente às
vezes não quer mostrar para os outros
esse quadro aqui é do pablo picasso
ele basicamente representa pra gente o
que a gente considera dentro da
identidade autêntica porque o picasso ea
cubista
só que nesse quadro ele resolveu não
seguir os padrões que o cubismo é
representa que seriam formas geométricas
ele decidiu colocar um pouco mais a sua
autenticidade e conseguiu quebrar um
padrão então por que você tem as suas
necessidades de está dentro do padrão
obrigada obrigada
[Aplausos]